great um ostrich thanks for the intro
Michael Jennifer and the others thanks
for inviting me today I'm going to talk
about joint work with matt jackson on
tractable and consistent random graph
models we're going to do this by cutting
the paper into and i'm going to talk
about the statistical half of the paper
and Matt's going to talk about the
strategic foundations of random Network
models um but in the spirit of what ah
she's just talked about and what Michael
talked about yesterday I want to step
back for a second and try to situate
this in the broader context relating
network formation to behavioral networks
um so the way we in the social sciences
think about this generally is that you
have a collection of agents these might
be people there might be firms countries
whatever unit you care about and the
agents are situated in an environment
right so the environment is the set of
interactions that it's a set of
parameters that determines payoffs for
the interactions that are going to
perform for instance maybe I just like
to have friends so I care about a
popularity game or maybe I know that I'm
going to learn information from someone
so I want to actually make friends in a
certain way and so whatever the
environment is this actually generates
incentives to form a graph but this
generates incentives to form a social
network and a lot of the network
formation literature from our vantage
point is about this particular space of
course once you have the fabric of
society having been constructed there's
another thing that happens right so we
have a collection of friends and my
friend learns that Kanye West released a
new song and he tells me and I tell my
friend so you have sort of diffusion on
the graph or maybe a sequence of
financial flows amongst countries or
amongst banks or so on and so forth and
so basically what you have is given that
you have a collection of units in a
graph you have an interaction and then
you see sort of observed behavior right
so this is kind of the broad the broad
set of data that is at our disposal um
there too so this is fine and in some
sense you could think about just
modeling all of this with a very simple
statistical model um that's very
descriptive of the features but there
are two broad problems right um so the
first is what we call endogeneity so by
endogeneity what i mean is that you
might have
agents who have particular taste for
things right so I have taste for pop
culture gossip so no matter what I'm
going to go online and I'm going to
consume it now just because Matt also
has taste for this gossip doesn't mean
that there's a diffusion here I'm not
learning about the gossip from him it's
just that we have unobserved features
that actually affect the outcome we're
interested in but like not through the
social network and so a lot of the
analysis of social networks miss
attributes a graph influencing behavior
when it's actually agents types
influencing paper right and so a lot of
people including people in this room
have worked on this problem and the
second issue and in some sense it's less
discussed is how behavior then feeds
back and changes the graph structure so
when I can metrics we call the
simultaneity the basic ideas I know that
Matt is standing me with things I don't
like and so I'm just going to maybe go
in sever linked right so the graph
evolves in response to the behavior um
and then you can think about this entire
system as an equilibrium where we have
agents in an environment they behave but
that behavior feeds back on the graph
structure and you can think about
descriptive statistical models of this
describing could have reduced from
correlations of this entire process but
what we're interested in in some sense
is these channels so we care about going
from graph to behavior in a causal way
and we care about thinking about what
are the agents what are the incentives
that agents face that sort of generate
network formation right so we want to
sort of break this apart um so this
channel is often studied in empirical
work going from grass to behavior um and
this is where experiments basically live
right so the way people do this is they
sort of fix a graph and how people do a
learning task a coordination test
michael has a million papers on this and
they identified these sorts of things
right um there's less empirical work on
this which is how do you identify how
agents how can causally identify how
agents go from their incentives to
forming networks um again Michael is
presenting something on this later but
but the broad point is that this is
really difficult because it depends on
the nature of the environment okay
okay so so where's the paper we I'm
going to talk about live it lives in
this space and it's just about the
statistics of this space okay um I don't
need to talk about that so so so now
sort of narrowing in there's a class of
models that a number of people and the
social sciences and statistics
literature use called exponential random
graph models it's been sort of
extensively studied for the last 20 30
years and the basic idea is that the
probability of a network being bored
depends on structural features of the
graph the vector of sufficient
statistics for instance how many links
are present how many triangles are
present how many other features are
present right and so intuitively it
looks like this so I want the
probability of a graph being born to
depend on the number of links the graph
has the number of triangles it has and
so maybe I'll just make the probability
of the graph being born proportional to
the exponential function of this right
turns out there's a theorem there that
says you can represent sort of all
probability distributions of a graphs in
some version of this not a specific
statistics but some version like this so
people became sort of began to fall in
love with this representation um so so
the general way to look at this model is
that the probability of graph depends on
the exponential of some vector of
statistics that are in this sort of
linear in parameters form in the
exponential right where the statistic is
often the number of copies of some given
sub graph within the parent graph so you
might think it's the number of triangles
the number of stars and number of Link's
features like this straight um the
problem though is that if you look at
how this probability is defined the
denominator is huge so if you think
about n nodes there's this is the space
on two to the n choose 2 right so this
is this is gigantic and so obviously you
can't directly compute this and so what
the literature is done is developed mcmc
techniques for estimation where they
sort of sample the space and try to
estimate what these probabilities are
right so they walk this base and try to
give estimates of this probability and
using this they try to estimate the
parameters they care about but it turns
out these
procedures are largely imperfect in a
way that the literature sort of
understands um so one failing is that
for a number of desirable models that we
might care about where we care about
things like links and also triangles and
other structures the mcmc takes
exponential time to mix the essential
you can't use it unless the graph
basically looks like a nerd asrani graph
right um and so that sort of result
generates a lot of pessimism about this
class of models um but of course these
sorts of results are hard to come by and
they're only proven in the case of dense
graphs okay um the reason that's
important though is because most of the
graphs is we discussed a bit earlier
yesterday that we're interested in are
largely sparse straight and so so so we
still want to know whether or not
there's degeneracy problems in this
farce case um so so what I'm going to do
is first I'm going to talk about a new
perspective on this class of models i'm
going to show you that this class of
models has problems even in sparse case
and discuss how we're going to frame the
problem in a new statistical sense and
the basic idea is we're going to focus
on not thinking about the network as
generating sort of distributions of the
links per se but we're going to think
about breaking the graph into pieces
we're going to break them into sub sub
graphs that are our essential basis to
form the graph and think about
distributions over that and that's going
to simplify the problem then I'm going
to point out that this generates very
nice statistical properties the
parameters are consistently estimable
and asymptotically normally distributed
that's great and they're very very easy
to estimate and then what Matt's going
to talk about our strategic micro
foundations that give rise to Matt
models like these so are the you know
behavioral games that give rides to
these sorts of models and how do we
think about various hypotheses and sort
of economics that we care about that we
can tackle through the lens of this
model okay so I'm going to take a very
simple example here um consider a model
in which sub groups of nodes are going
to sometimes meet and they're going to
make structures at random and these
structures are just going to be clicks
and specifically here if three people
meet they decide whether or not to make
it click and if two people meet they
decide whether or not to make a link
that's it okay and this is sort of one
shot
ok they don't repeatedly meet this is a
one-shot thing you can think about
estimating this through the lens of an
exponential random graph models so the
probability of G is going to depend on
these three statistics SI is going to be
the countif isolates in the graph how
many people have no link right SL is
going to be the number of edges in the
graph how many links are out there in
the graph and st is going to be how many
triangles are out there in the graph and
sort of conditional on this vector of
sufficient statistics any graph with
these three exact counts is drawn
uniformly at random right so that's the
model that's positive yeah right so
that's that's a good question I'm sorry
for not being clear so the thought
experiment we're doing here with one
large graph and then later on the
asymptotic sequence we're going to think
about is sort of a sequin one sort of an
array of like large graphs like going to
infinity if it's just one drop and so we
care about right right so there's a
sense in which they're still information
there that can deliver a consistency
because um so so I'll come to that point
that out when we look at it from the
perspective for our model but the but
there is more information so just like a
time series is one draw of time series
data that's correlated over time but it
could be broken into chunks that give
you limit theorems this also has
potential for data for you know limit
theorems like that so but that's not the
problem gonna complain about right now
ok um so so I'm going to do this with 50
nodes uh and and I'm actually going to
just give myself exact count so they're
going to be 20 isolates 45 links and 10
triangles okay um this is going to
roughly correspond to having the
probability of someone being isolated at
a third the probability if a link
forming if any two people meet to be
this number and the probability of any
triple of people who meet forming a
triangle to be at this number okay so so
the whole idea about fixing graphs with
these counts is that they basically have
the same sufficient statistic now so
when you run this model you should
basically get the same parameters back
and this should be centered correctly
okay so this is just a test um so this
is so what I've done here is run like a
thousand runs
of estimating up these graphs and and
you know without any other information
it's not obvious you know so the x axis
shows the distribution of these
parameters in that you shouldn't know
what this means right this is just the
Maxis the one point to make is that that
solid red line represents both the right
and the left hand side of the
ninety-five percent confidence interval
on centered around the median parameter
estimate so you can see that inference
is bad off the bat just based on this
procedure and this is because they're
not getting the sort of the they're not
getting the variance estimate correctly
from this procedure um so to show you
what this means what I did was I took
these drawers and I generated graphs I
generated a sequence of graphs from each
of these parameter values to give you a
sense what this means so look this is
heaped around 20 once in a while you get
this fully degenerate graft seeped
around 20 so it's usually not awful that
sometimes it could be okay my closet
feel free did ya defer this question is
it might be an aggression bit so you
have this exponential model yes over a
set of features that kept invented for
network property yeps so this is very
reminiscent of maths entropy and so I'm
wondering and the other the hard problem
there is computing the partition
function which is yours isn't this is
that problem but then you mentioned it
it sort of the easy case is when the
graph is dense or heritage ready like in
order to show that the mcmc breaks down
they were able to prove it in the dense
case that it breaks down the NC NC break
so so my intuition here right is that in
general sort of sparsity is what would
make calculations tracleer like I mean
sort of computing the partition function
formats entropy on a tree is like a
dynamic programming exercise right right
as you move right right right things get
hard so I'm wondering how that plays out
here right so if you give me so I'm
going to come to an intuition like that
that's going to be the basis of what we
want to do it this is just a point out
that this widely used model breaks down
miserably so here we're doing okay now
let's look at links links the only thing
to take aways this thing is negative
this thing is positive it's kind of all
over the place inference is really bad
again here's the confidence intervals
you shouldn't
what that means but if I plot out what's
the link clowns implied are from those
parameters there is sort of around 350
links or the empty graph remember i
started with 45 i generated a grass with
45 links so that's sort of centered
wrong and finally if you look at the
triangle parameter so it's it's hiep
that it's heaped at this point we don't
know what that means just yet um but
it's distributed pretty broadly and if
you look there's about 2,000 triangles
in the graph ok so the estimates we're
getting off the sufficient statistics
we've basically held fixed or way off
okay so so the takeaway is that even for
these fixed values of the stats you get
unstable estimates with unreasonable
chains of graphs that are being drawn
from the distribution by the procedure
with crazy and friends procedures ok so
it's broken um but the model is really
easy to describe right I just said that
links were born and triangles are born
and the and and some nodes were chosen
to be isolates it was very very easy to
describe so this problem shouldn't be
that hard right um so what we're going
to do is we're going to say look and
this is sort of your observation right
that there are lots of grass but their
way fewer possible statistics I mean so
we can collapse all the equivalent
networks to sufficient statistics right
these sort of equivalence classes so the
basic idea is we have this exponential
random breath model let's take the sum
let's sum over all the values of the
possible counts of links and triangles
right in the denominator and then let's
sum over all the values again in the
numerator and so now I'm just asking
what's the probability that I see a
graph with K links L triangles and Z
isolates well it's just given by sort of
this expression and our problems are
reduced or how easy or hard counting how
many graphs of a typical type there are
in this sense and it turns out even this
problem is very very hard computing
these numbers is hard perfect but so
asking yourself how many grafts are out
there with 17 ISIL s45 links and 20
triangles is quite hard on it notes
right but the second observation to make
is that there's nothing special about
thinking about grass being born from
this distribution ok for historical
reasons they sort of done this in this
literature but there's nothing special
about using this sort of
counting measure as the wait for a
probability of craft being born right so
in principle you could use any other
thing as your sort of physical the
reference distribution in principle you
can use any other thing to do the
weighting of the graphs right there's
nothing sacred about this and in fact in
the model i'm going to show you sort of
over the next 10 minutes it turns out
this isn't even the natural waiting that
you'd want to give two graphs okay so so
sort of the general way we're thinking
about this problem is the probability
that you see a graph with the given
vector of sufficient statistics like a
given link count given edge count is
going to be proportional to some
weighting function over the statistics
times the exponential of beta times
those statistics right so that's kind of
the general form of this model and so
the claim is for different classes of
these functions this model is or isn't
consistently estimable right and
moreover this object itself is or isn't
computable right and that could simplify
both the computational problem and the
statistical problem okay so that's kind
of the broad overview um okay so so we
don't need this okay um so so going back
to our example so you can think about
rewriting our isolates links and
triangle example as just we have some
new k right are we wait by K the this
this expression to say what's the
probability of seeing a graph with this
many isolates dis many links to this
many triangles um and the only
difference relative to what we had
before is before that was just the
actual number of grafts that had this
many links this many eye slits and as
many triangles and now we're going to
sort of free that up in a second okay
and it and and it turns out if we use
sort of like binomials here the our
world gets very simple that's where I'm
going okay so so this is the first class
of models we're interested in we call
these sir gums we call them statistical
exponential random graph models because
what we did was we collapse the problem
to the space of sufficient statistics
and then we allow ourselves to change
the reference distribution um so the
second model very related that we're
interested in its taking formation in
the following
so nature is going to form sk subgraphs
for each type of sub graph k with some
probability PK right so this means that
links are formed some probability
triangles are formed at some probability
well any structure you want sort of this
form to some probability okay and these
things for the fall from the sky and
they may intersect they may even overlap
and the observe and then the observing
and what we do is we observe the
resulting graph we're going to use this
sort of back out these probabilities
okay so this is you know a slice of some
network data that we're looking at we
want to model this these are nodes and
we think that there's some probability
by which these triangles are born and
then given that the triangles are born
there's some probability by which links
are drawn and once in a while on
accident you get an extra triangle which
comes from they overlap okay okay but
it's pretty easy to decompose in this
way okay so so the reason for saying
this is then if we turn to the example
that I began with it's actually very
easy right so how do you compute the
probability that a node is an isolate on
this if we thought that this was the
generating process well it's just the
count of the isolates over N right
that's trivial and then what's the
probability that a node is a you know
what's the probability that triangle is
born well it's just then a triangle
count over sort of n choose three where
n is sort of less the isolates right and
then what's the probability of a link
being born well here again so a link is
an object that's a link that's not a
member of a triangle that's how we're
interpreting a link right so we call
this an unsupported link um well this is
just how many links we observe how many
unsupported links we serve minus how
many sort of you know how many potential
link realizations are could have been
right and we have three probabilities
there um and that's that's very easy
right it's just binomials and it turns
out you can actually map this exactly
back to these exponential forms right so
the way you go from PS back to these
Thetas and the exponential form is just
log odds ratios of these objects and
then you can use binomial coefficients
to ask yourself how many ways can you
draw this many isolates how many ways
can you draw this mailings I'm
anyways can you draw this main triangles
okay um yeah yes I'm gonna get to
exactly this yeah that's exactly right
so I to the general model fibrin okay
perfect okay so I presented sort of this
general model first and i talked about
how you can vary these reference
distributions and by doing that you can
play with consistency i'm not going to
talk about it though so struck it out
but but but sort of the paper does that
what i want address is exactly this
question which is in some sense how am i
doing this counting trick and what where
am i where's kind of the rabbit going in
that so so the large-scale observation
is what many economic networks have the
following feature that there's a lot of
interdependencies between links so
there's sort of too much clustering but
they're highly sparse right so it's that
they're mostly empty it's not that
they're mostly full and so we're going
to exploit sparsity and were going to
count in a specific way um so so the
problem we were worried about just
reviews of incidental generation of
objects so if you thought that a
triangle is born between nodes 1 2 & 4
and another triangle is born between 32
and five and then a link was born like a
pure link was born between one and three
well the problem is you've created this
this extra triangle right so that's kind
of the problem we want to avoid okay so
what we're going to do is we're going to
consider it sort of any so some finite
vector of constant extent this case it
might be a save triangles and links and
we're going to say they're nicely
ordered if the subnetwork counted by the
first object we count can't be a sub
network of i start the subnetwork if the
second thing we count isn't a sub
network of the first thing we counted
right so for example if we look at
triangles we care about unsupported
links for counting links that aren't
members of triangles if we think about a
model over for clicks triangles and
links then we count all the four clicks
first then we pull them out then we
count all treat triangles that board
members of clicks these four clicks we
pull them out and then we look at the
links that weren't members of either of
these higher order strength right so so
this is just a simple accounting access
we say that I nicely ordered um uh sort
of nice so like a graph with nice order
statistics is relatively sparse under
some sequence of probability parameters
if essentially um for every type the
expected number of incidentally generate
sub graph counted by that type vanishes
relative to the expected number of
directly generated types right so it's
basically saying that this problem
doesn't happen too often and so the way
you need to do that is you need to think
about all the objects you're going to
count and then you need to figure out
what are all the ways in which you could
accidentally generate something and sort
of bound that and the condition that we
talked about in the paper sort of talks
about what you need to be able to bound
by what I want to highlight here is sort
of what this implies for us like could
this be useful for realistic rest right
so so what this allows you to do is you
could think about you know the
probability of these links being born on
the like little o of 1 over root n and
the probability for triangle being born
being a little o of n to the minus
three-halves what do these rates imply
this means that the typical node is in
fewer than order root end links and root
end triangles but those sorts of rates
are entirely reasonable for the data
that we often look at right because
these are pretty sparse graphs and these
are pretty slowly growing of degree in
triangle accounts so models of this
variety it can actually be pretty easily
covered by this sort of exercise okay um
so so then what's the result the result
is that if you take these probability
parameters for every object that you're
going to count you sort of do the
appropriate normalization because as the
network gets big these probability
parameters are going to 0 it's sort of
some rate there's a you know very
straightforward binomial style of
central limit theorem there you can
estimate these things consistently and
sort of their parameter estimates are
normally distributed okay not very
surprising but the second point I want
to highlight is it's extremely easy to
add individual level traits in this
model it's very very easy to add
covariance so i can ask myself what's
the probability that you know someone
from penn and someone from stanford are
going to be friends and it can't add all
these probabilities by attributes of
notes right there's nothing sacred about
not have
attributes in this model right since its
accounting exercise this is patently
obvious if it's discreet if all nodes
have types then this is just making
cells of types and counting them right
and it's very very easy to do it even if
the covariance are continuous even if
they're sort of interdependent there's
nothing very sacred about them being
discreet cooker right um and so so when
I want to sort of clothes on is actually
give you a very very simple way that one
might be able to sort of use this in
practice just chill straight how easy it
is to do so imagine that you have a
graph and you have a covariant vector
for every node you have some attributes
for every node in the graph okay the
first day and imagine I'm want to fit a
model where I look at four clicks
triangles and links i think that that's
my theory of the world okay so then you
can pick a nicely order set of
statistics here for clicks triangles and
links and the first thing you do is you
just stack your data so you look at all
four clicks so you look at all
quadruples of your data and you just ask
what's the probability of ijkl being in
a four click given their attributes you
just run a regression right you get
parameter estimates of those slopes you
hang out to them and we can show sort of
under appropriate regularity conditions
that this will be sort of consistent and
normally distributed then you just zero
out everything you just use so i used
all these four clicks I tossed them and
then I look at triangles and I run a
regression of what's the probability of
triangles being born given attributes of
those nodes now again so sorry this is
my poor notation for a logistic
regression so this is the probability
that a four clique is born given some
vector of covariance this is just a
logistic function okay um and so now you
just run a regression on all triples of
whether or not triangle is born given
covariance you hang on to those
parameters u 0 now all four clicks in
all triangles are 0 I mean just pull
them out of your data now you run a
regression on pairs whether or not edges
success given vector the cover okay and
this stack of parameters are actually
sort of behaved in a in a nice
statistical sense that we care about you
can do inference on them and so that's
that's very very easy to do write this
you could do in five minutes on your
computer um
so to close I just want to say um what I
wanted to highlight here is very very
simple models of grass formation where
we're trying to emphasize the idea that
sub graphs might be the right unit to
model the interdependencies so we think
about decoupling the graph as having a
basis of these different objects and
they're sort of stacked together Oh this
boat gives us intuition as to how you
could go about estimating exponential
random graph type models but in the
sparse case you could do very very
direct things as well just these
counting arguments and be able to model
these things they're very very desirable
statistical properties and their
absurdly easy to implement um and I
think what Matt's going to cover is sort
of how well does this do in practice
does this replicate the correlation
structure in a real empirical network
data that we care about for instance we
have a deck of 75 Indian village
networks and we try to see whether or
not this does a reasonable job with that
and also how does this relate to
strategic foundations for these models
are there models of interactions amongst
agents that we think that make that give
rise to the idea that these sub graphs
are the right units that we think about
is the basic building blocks of behavior
and and if so then we want to think
about doing statistics with those
objects thank you